virus is clearly out of control and
there's no good the prime minister
hinting that further restrictions are
coming
to place in a week or two or three that
delay has been the source of so many
problems
so i say bringing those restrictions now
national restrictions within the next 24
hours that has to be the first step to
controlling
the virus on schools i don't want to add
to the chaos
that would be caused by having all
schools close tomorrow many will be
closed it is inevitable more schools are
going to have to close
and the government needs a plan for
children's learning but also for working
parents so it is inevitable that more
schools are going to
close many will be closed tomorrow
morning but the more important thing in
a way is the national restrictions need
to come in in the next 24 hours
let's not have the prime minister saying
i'm going to do it but not yet
that's the problem he's made so many
times so you're clear on that
nationwide lockdown should come in in
the next 24 hours
nationwide lockdown the prime minister
is hinting
that that's gonna happen but he's
delaying again
and we can't afford that again we can't
allow the prime minister to use up the
next two or three weeks and then bring
in the national
lock down that is inevitable do it now
that's the necessary first step
to get the virus back under control so
what do you say to the prime minister
about
his viewpoint that it's important for
children to be in school where possible
if it's important for their
mental health or wellbeing it's
important for parents
schools are safe and those parents that
have the option to send their
children back to school tomorrow should
do so everybody wants children back in
school there's nobody that would argue
with that of course that's what we all
want
it is inevitable that some schools won't
be open tomorrow morning we know that
the prime minister's accepted that
it's inevitable more schools will close
i don't want to call for the closure of
schools
tomorrow morning and add to the chaos
but we do need to recognize that it's
inevitable that more schools will close
and we need a plan in place to deal with
that but it can only be part of a wider
strategy that has a national lock down
in place
in the next 24 hours the prime
minister's hinting at it
but he's not doing it and we can't
afford that delay again you say it's
inevitable
more schools will close do you think all
schools in england
should close and if so when i'm not
saying all schools should close nobody
wants that that should be the last
resort not the first resort the national
lockdown that's necessary has to come
first we can't have retail open in some
places
and schools closed but it is inevitable
i'm afraid
now the government has lost control of
virus that more schools will be closed
in addition to those that are closed
tomorrow we can't just be blind to that
we need a plan in place to allow
children to learn and working parents
have a plan of how they're going to
balance that life so just to be clear on
this uh
this lockdown you're saying a nationwide
lockdown that
education stays open well possible
many many schools are not going to be
open tomorrow
it's inevitable i think that more
schools will be closed and we've got to
face up to that
but that should be the last resort the
first thing is the national lockdown
that needs to be in place in the next 24
hours
not hinting that it's going to happen in
two or three or four weeks time
do it now what about the damage that
does to the economy
to jobs to people's well-being another
another nationwide lockdown
what we have what we've learned
is that the longer you delay the
difficult decisions
the worse it is on the health front the
worse it is on the economic front
and delaying an inevitable decision
again that's been the hallmark of this
prime minister we can't go around that
track again